[Music]
welcome to Oslo and to the Oslo City
Hall where the Nobel Peace Prize
ceremony will take place today as every
year on December 10th which is also the
International Human Rights Day
[Music]
the royal family will soon arrive here
at the entrance to the city
[Music]
in 2017 the recipient of the Peace Prize
is the icon the international campaign
to abolish nuclear weapons often those
who receive the prize
our president state leaders and other
prominent figures this year there is a
group of more everyday people ten years
ago they had the idea to form an
organization to prohibit nuclear weapons
and as the process that I started in the
United Nations last summer now is signed
by 122 countries they are here in Oslo
today to receive the Nobel Prize the
fight the fight against nuclear weapons
has been long the human made its first
resolution against the deadly weapons in
1946 and in 1985 the organization
physicians against nuclear weapons
received the Peace Prize the icon has
468 local organizations in more than a
hundred countries
the Nobel Committee feels that it is
important to honor those who have
suffered from nuclear weapons and will
tell the world about it so several of
those who survived the 1945 bombing of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in Japan are
present in the whole today present are
also survivors of nuclear tests in
different parts of the world
the mayors of Hiroshima and Nagasaki are
also in the city hall today several
ambassadors are among the audience as
usual but the ambassador's of the
nuclear powers are asked the
ambassador's in Norway for the United
States Russia France United Kingdom
India and Pakistan did not wish to be
present Israel is the only nuclear power
who is represented by its ambassador
today the other nuclear powers this way
is showing there this as if this
satisfaction with today's price
as every year there are beautiful
flowers in the city hall there are
carnations amaryllis for save and many
others the decorator Toby Anoka son has
been raising the flowers in the City
Hall on December 10th for the last 22
years the Peace Prize diploma this year
is created by years the priest price
diploma this year is created by Thomas V
the berry indelible stone stones pastry
depicts mother love and our wish for
children to grow up in a peaceful world
the theme for this year's diploma around
the thousand guests have taken their
seats in the hall waiting for prize
winners and a royal family
on the right side of the aisle are the
foreign guests and in the first row the
leaders of the econ on the other side
are representatives of official Norway
head of Parliament only Mika Thomason
Prime Minister and sold by and her
husband and head of Supreme Court oral
Maria among many other Norwegian
politicians Norway as a state has not
supported that I can ban on nuclear
weapons as neither have the other NATO
countries
tomorrow is the traditional Nobel
concert host this British actor David
Oyelowo some of the other artists will
be seen at the concert tomorrow are also
here today one of the stars from the
concert John Legend will also sing here
at the ceremony today and here is also
his wife and also signal of a young
Norwegian artist who will perform
tomorrow also at the concert the first
guests have been here for some time
already
and have taken the opportunity to see
the beautiful decorations in the hole on
the wall facing the seaside is Henrik
surgeons well-known painting dominating
the world here we can see Cong Hawking
Hawken of Norway welcomed home after
five years away during World War two and
the upper part of the painting we see a
woman charity giving a Golden Apple to a
child on the upside this side of the
hall is Alf Rosen's large fresco with
themes from the witch and working life
the Norwegian Discoverer Fridtjof Nansen
also here in this picture is also a
recipient of the Peace Prize
time
so here the royal family is arriving at
the city hall their royal family is
always present at this event
His Majesty King Harald met by Mariana
Bergen the mayor of Oslo and then Queen
Sonja and then Crown Prince Haakon and
chrome princess Mehta married
[Music]
and so the police waves procession
enters the whole accompanied by members
as a Nobel Committee to the left air the
atmosphere the leader by the icon
accompanied by henrik cecil and behind
him
Setsuko Thurlow
6:02 Turlough experience the atom bomb
thrown over Hiroshima in August 1945
when she was 13 years old now she is 85
and very active in the icon
and so the two Prize winners today with
members of the Nobel Committee take
their usual places in the hall and no
members of the army band is playing the
fanfare again as the royal family
venture sir
King and committee with beta minus
emission Queen Sonia accompanied by
Secretary William york-style when the
crown prince and Crown Princess and the
neighbor was low Mariana Burton coming
up to the usual places for the royal
family at this event
with everybody present in the whole the
ceremony as usual we'll start with music
Norwegian soprano be at the Moodle with
Howard games at the piano will sing Pam
from ballads by twittering strim lyrics
by Bookman
[Music]
and after a beautiful recently that I
must confer Nobel Committee leader
Barrett rise Anderson to give her speech
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
distinguished representatives of the
Nobel Peace Prize laureate your
excellencies distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen the international campaign
to abolish nuclear weapons ICANN has
been awarded the Nobel Peace Prize for
2017 on behalf of the Norwegian Nobel
Committee I take great pleasure in
congratulating I can on its award
I am is receiving the award for its work
to draw attention to the catastrophic
humanitarian consequences of any use of
nuclear weapons and for its
groundbreaking efforts to achieve a
treaty based prohibition of such weapons
icons efforts have given new momentum to
the process of abolishing nuclear
weapons
this year's Peace Prize follows in a
tradition of awards that have honored
efforts against nue against the
proliferation of nuclear weapons and for
nuclear disarmament 12-piece prizes have
been awarded in whole or in part for
this type of peace work the first went
to Philip known Baker in 1959 and the
recent award to Barack Obama in 2009 and
now this year to icon on two days in
August 1945 the world experienced the
terrible destructive force of nuclear
weapons for the first time the bombings
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki instantly
killed at least hundred and forty
thousand people the vast majority of
whom were civilians Hiroshima was
utterly destroyed and large sections of
Nagasaki were laid in ruins but death
was not finished with Hiroshima and
Nagasaki in August 1945 the death toll
continued to rise significantly in the
years that followed and survivors are
still today suffering from the effects
of radiation the devastation of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki has taught us
that nuclear weapons are so dangerous
and inflict so much agony and death on
civilian populations that they must
never ever be used again
today's nuclear weapons are tremendously
more destructive than the bombs that
were dropped in Japan in 1945 a nuclear
war could kill millions of people
dramatically alter climate and the
environment for much of the planet and
destabilize societies in a way never
before seen by humanity the notion of a
limited nuclear war is an illusion
nuclear weapons do not distinguish
between military and civilian targets
used in war they would impact
disproportionately
on the civilian population inflicting
vast unnecessary suffering it is
virtually impossible for civilians to
protect themselves against the
catastrophic consequences of nuclear
attack the use of nuclear weapons or
even the threat of using them is
therefore unacceptable by any ground
weather humanitarian moral or legal
despite all this the case that the
global the case is that the global
balance military but powers is
maintained by nuclear weapons the logic
of this balance of Terror rests on the
proportion proposition that nuclear
weapons are such a deterrent that no one
would dare to attack a nuclear-armed
state the deterrent effect is said to be
so strong that it alone has prevented
war between the nuclear powers for the
last 70 years the empirical basis for
this assumption is highly debatable it
cannot be claimed with any certainty
that deterrence has worked
as intended it is also worth keeping in
mind that nuclear deterrence requires a
credible threat to actually use nuclear
weapons the weapons exist so that they
can if necessary be deployed a number of
international agreements and treaties
have been entered into which limit the
position possession and development of
nuclear weapons the most important of
these is the treaty on the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons or
NPT it takes considerable military and
political insight to fully understand
all the treaties agreements and
international legal instruments that
regulate disarmament and arms control
the views that dominate the political
debate are those of the great powers and
powerful alliances Eiken arrows as a
protest against the established order
nuclear weapon issues are not solely a
question to be addressed by governments
nor a matter for experts or high-level
politicians nuclear weapons concern
everyone and everybody is entitled to an
opinion icon has he succeeded in
generating fresh engagement among
ordinary people in the campaign against
nuclear weapons the organization's
acronym
perhaps not a coincidence I can icons
main message is that the world can never
be safe as long as we have nuclear
weapons the message resonates with
millions of people who perceive that the
threat of nuclear war is greater than it
has been for a long time not least to
the situation in North Korea
another major concern of Ikon is that
the current international legal order is
inadequate to deal with a nuclear
weapons problem the entry into force of
the non-proliferation treaty in 1970 was
an historical breakthrough it gave
formal status to the nuclear powers of
the day the United States the Soviet
Union United Kingdom France and China as
states with a legal right to possess
nuclear weapons all other countries that
acceded to the treaty pledged in so
doing not to acquire such weapons in
return the legally recognized nuclear
weapon States undertook to begin
negotiations in good faith to seek
nuclear disarmament
this dual pledge is the very core of the
non-proliferation treaty and both sides
of it must be honored to maintain the
treaties legitimacy but ladies and
gentlemen it is no exaggeration to say
that a nuclear weapon states have only
to a limited degree honored this pledge
and the disarmament commitment they made
in the NPT
let me remind you that in the year 2000
the NPT review conference stated that
the treaty calls for an unequivocal
undertaking by the nuclear weapon States
to accomplish the total elimination of
their Arsenal's
leading to nuclear disarmament from an
international law perspective the five
legally recognized nuclear weapon states
and their allies have thus assumed the
responsibility to help achieve
disarmament and the world free of
nuclear weapons if the disarmament
process had been carried out as intended
I can struggle for a treaty based ban on
nuclear weapons would have been needed
it is the lack of progress towards
nuclear disarmament that has made the
necessity to supplement the
non-proliferation treaty with other
international legal initiatives and
commitments the NPT applies only to the
countries that have acceded to it India
Pakistan and Israel which all have
nuclear weapons are not NPT members
moreover North Korea which has carried
out six nuclear test explosions has
withdrawn from the treaty global nuclear
disarmament cannot take place without
these countries - participating yet they
reserved themselves the same right to
nuclear weapons as the five states that
has acquired such weapons prior to
nineteen seven
the five legally recognized nuclear
weapon states for their part cite the
nuclear arsenals for these countries are
one of the several arguments for not yet
beginning to comply with empathise
nuclear disarmament requirements it is
part to this vicious cycle that I can
has advocated a universal treaty based
ban on nuclear weapons
I can does not accept that the lack of
progress towards nuclear disarmament is
a realpolitik necessity icons premise is
humanitarian maintaining that any use of
nuclear weapons will cause unacceptable
human suffering binding international
prohibitions have already been
established for chemical weapons
biological weapons land mines and
cluster weapons precisely because of the
on of the harm and suffering that these
weapons inflict on civilian populations
it defies common sense that nuclear
weapons which are far more dangerous are
not subject to a comparable ban under
international law pointing out this
legal gap was crucial first step on the
road to a prohibition treaty another
important step was the humanitarian
pledge initiated by the Austrian
government in December 2014 the pledge
is a voluntary national commitment to
seek to
Maki's prohibit and eliminate nuclear
weapons ICANN has worked resolutely to
muster broad international support for
the humanitarian pledge to date a
hundred and twenty nine states have
signed on to this commitment ICANN has
also been a driving force in efforts to
secure a binding international ban of
nuclear weapons
on 7 July 2017 a final draft treaty was
endorsed by 129 UN member states the
treaty on the prohibition of nuclear
weapons opened up four signatures this
autumn and has been signed so far by 56
States when 50 or more states have also
ratified the treaty it will become
binding under international law and for
the signatory States
I can is a young organization founded in
2007 on the initiative of the
international physicians for the
Prevention of nuclear war which won the
Nobel Peace Prize in 1985 ICANN is a
loose coalition of 468 NGOs from more
than 100 countries it is impressive that
I can is able to unite so many different
groups in support for a common goal and
give a voice to millions of people who
are convinced that nuclear weapons do
not provide security
but in security in awarding this year's
Peace Prize to Ikon the Norwegian Nobel
Committee seeks the honor this
remarkable endeavor to serve the
interest of mankind the Nobel Committee
believes that an international ban on
nuclear weapons will be an important and
possibly decisive step on the road to a
world without nuclear weapons such a
goal is fully consistent with the
essence of Alfred Nobel's will ladies
and gentlemen I can support for a global
ban on nuclear weapons is not
uncontroversial we must acknowledge that
the treaty has powerful opponents but
the idea of prohibiting and abolishing
nuclear weapons is neither naive nor is
it new as early as in 1946 in the UN
General Assembly's very first resolution
the United Nations called for nuclear
disarmament and international nuclear
weapons control regime at the right of
Exxon
in 1986 Micahel gabacho and Ronald
Reagan tried to halt the spiraling
nuclear arms race between the two
superpowers and came close to concluding
an agreement to abolish all long-range
missiles a year and a half earlier
President Reagan had addressed the
people of the United States and the
Soviet Union directly by saying a
nuclear war cannot be won and must never
be fought the only value in our two
nations possessing nuclear weapons is to
make sure they will never be used but
then would it not be better to do away
with them entirely today it is more
important than ever to support this
vision while the global community may
trust that no responsible head of state
would ever order another nuclear attack
we have no guarantees that it will not
happen despite international legal
commitments irresponsible leaders can
come to power in any nuclear-armed state
and become embroiled in serious military
conflict that we're out of control
ultimately nuclear weapons are
controlled by human beings in spite of
advanced security mechanisms and control
systems technical and human errors can
occur with potentially catastrophic
consequences can we be sure that the
control system
of the nuclear powers will not someday
be sabotage by hackers acting on the
behalf of hostile states terrorists or
extremists in short nuclear weapons are
so dangerous that the only responsible
course of action is to work for their
removal and destruction many people
think that the vision of a nuclear
weapon-free world global zero is your
topic or even irresponsible similar
arguments were once used to oppose the
treaties banning biological and chemical
weapons cluster weapons and landmines
nonetheless the prohibitions became a
reality and most of these weapons are
far less prevalent today as a result
using them is taboo ladies and gentlemen
the Norwegian Nobel Committee is aware
that nuclear weapons disarmament
presents far greater challenges than
disarmament of the types of weapons I
just mentioned but there is no getting
around the fact that the nuclear weapon
states have committed through the NPT to
work towards disarmament this is the
ultimate objective of the treaty through
its efforts ICANN has reminded the
nuclear weapon states that their
commitment entails a genuine obligation
and the time to honor it is now
in his Nobel lecture in 1959 Filipino
Baker took issue with the widely held
opinion that complete nuclear
disarmament is impossible to achieve in
the real world he quoted another Peace
Prize laureate treaty of nonsan and he
said the difficult is what takes a
little while they're impossible
what is takes a little longer
the people of Ikon are impatient and
visionary but they are not naive
I can recognize is that the
nuclear-armed States cannot eliminate
their nuclear weapons overnight this
must be achieved through a mutual
gradual and verifiable disarmament
process but it is the hope of I can and
the Norwegian Nobel Committee that an
international legal ban and a broad
popular engagement will put pressure on
all nuclear-armed States and expedite
the process ladies and gentlemen there
are two persons on the podium today who
each in their way are outstanding
representatives of the icon movement
madam
Setsuko you were 13 years old when you
experienced the bombing of Hiroshima you
have devoted your life to bearing
witness to the events of 6 August 1945
you see it at Yom as your mission to
describe the suffering fear and death
inflicted on your city no one was spared
little children their parents brothers
sister's schoolmates and grandparents
were killed you say that war cannot be
waged in this way and it must never
happen again
you do not allow us to forget
Beatriz Finn you are the executive
director of Ikon and have a challenging
task of uniting different organizations
and interest groups in pursuit of the
common goal you are such a splendid
representative of the multitude of
idealists who forego an ordinary career
and instead devote all of their time and
skills to work for achieving a peaceful
world it is an honor to have you here as
our guests and we wish to express a deep
felt gratitude for the work that you do
and our tribute also goes to all the
individuals and organizations that both
of you represent
the decision to award the Nobel Peace
Prize for 2017 to Ikon has a solid
grounding in Alfred Nobel's will the
will specifies three different criteria
for awarding the peace price the
promotion of fraternity between nations
the advancement of disarmament and arms
control and the holding and promotion of
peace Congress's I can work vigorously
to achieve nuclear disarmament I can has
a majority of you and member states I
can and the majority of UN member states
have contributed to fraternity between
nations by supporting the humanitarian
pledge and through its inspiring and
innovative support for the UN
negotiations on a nuclear weapon ban
treaty ICANN has played an important
role in bringing about what in our day
and age is equivalent to an
international peace Congress in closing
I would like to quote His Holiness Pope
Francis who recently declared weapons of
mass destruction particularly nuclear
weapons create nothing but a false sense
of security they cannot constitute the
basis for peaceful coexistence between
members of the human family which must
rather be inspired by an ethics of
solidarity the Norwegian Nobel Committee
shares this view moreover it is a firm
conviction that I can more than anyone
else has in the power
year given the efforts to achieve a
world without nuclear weapons a new
direction and a new vigor thank you very
much
we will replace honestly speech and now
she called for these representatives to
be presented with this year's Nobel
Prize I now call upon the
representatives of the Nobel Peace Prize
laureate 2017 to step forward to receive
the diploma and the gold medal
so Beatrice Beatrice Finn and Setsuko
Thurlow will now receive the diploma and
medal
and very happy audience
a group
and this group I can endorse
and some a few seconds for the press
photographers to get their pictures I'll
be with it
the prize money is 8 million Swedish
parents
but there will be music before the
prizewinners speeches John Legend's will
sing Redemption song by Bob Marley
[Music]
Oh pirates yes they rob I sold I to the
merchant ships minutes have today took i
from the bottomless pit but my
[Music]
generation
try apparently won't you go to see
these
[Music]
retention song we - in song
some say it's just the part we got
[Music]
won't you sing these songs of freedom -
it's all
retention song
these are the freedom we don't solve
retention song retention
[Music]
[Applause]
John let's eat he will also say Matt the
Annabelle concept a moment
and after this music we shall hear the
prizewinners I now call upon miss
Beatrice Finn and Miss physical Thurlow
to give the Nobel Peace Prize lecture
for 2017 it will be one speech in two
parts and Beatrice Finn the floor is
yours your Majesties your Royal
Highnesses members of the Norwegian
Nobel Committee esteemed guests friends
campaigners colleagues today it is my
great honor to accept the 2017 Nobel
Peace Prize on behalf of the thousands
of inspirational people who make up the
international campaign to abolish
nuclear weapons I am just one member of
this huge grassroots movement who
together have brought democracy to
disarmament and are reshaping
international law we most humbly thank
than a we do Nobel Committee for
recognizing our work and giving momentum
to our crucial cause and we recognize
all of those who so generously donate
their time and energy to this campaign
all of icons partner organizations we
thank the courageous foreign ministers
diplomats Red Cross and Red Crescent
staff UN officials academics experts
with whom we have worked in partnership
to advance our common goal and we thank
all who are committed to rid in the
world
this terrible threat at dozens of
locations around the world in missile
silos buried in our ground on submarines
navigating through our oceans and aboard
planes flying high in our sky like
15,000 objects of humankind's
destruction and perhaps it is the
enormity of this fact perhaps it is the
unimaginable scale of the consequences
that leads many to simply accept this
grim reality to go about our daily lives
with no thought of the instruments of
insanity all around us for it is
insanity to allow ourselves to be ruled
by these weapons many critics of this
movement suggest that we are the
irrational ones the idealists
with no grounding in reality that
nuclear-armed States will never give up
their weapons but we represent the only
rational choice we represent those who
refuse to accept nuclear weapons as a
fixture in our world those who refuse to
have their fates bound up in a few lines
of launch code ours is the only reality
that is possible
the alternative is unthinkable the story
of nuclear weapons will have an ending
and it is up to us to decide what that
enemy will be will it be the end of
nuclear weapons or really be the end of
us one of these things will happen
the only rational course of action is to
cease living under the conditions where
our mutual destruction is only one
impulsive
away
and today I want to talk about three
things fear freedom and the future by
the very admission of those who system
the real utility of nuclear weapons is
in their ability to provoke fear when
they refer to their deterrent effects
proponents of nuclear weapons are
celebrating fear as a weapon of war they
are puffing their chests by declaring
the preparedness to exterminate in a
flash countless of thousands of human
lives
normal laureate William Faulkner said
when accepting his prize
in 1915 there is only the question of
when will I be blown up but since then
this universal fear has given way to
something even more dangerous
denial gone is the fear of Armageddon in
an instant
gone is the equilibrium between two
blocks that was used as a justification
for deterrence gone are the fallout
shelters but one thing remains the
thousands upon thousands of nuclear
warheads that filled us up with that
fear the risk of you nuclear weapons use
is even greater today than at the end of
the Cold War but unlike the Cold War
today we face many more nuclear-armed
States terrorists cyber warfare all of
this makes us less safe learning to live
with these weapons and blind acceptance
has been on next great mistake fear is
rational the threat is real we have
avoided nuclear war
not through prudent leadership but good
fortune and sooner or later if we fail
to act our luck will run out a moment of
panic or carelessness a misconstrued
comment or boosts ego
could easily lead us to the destruction
of entire cities a calculated military
escalation could lead to the
indiscriminate murder of civilians if
only a small fraction of today's nuclear
weapons were used ashes and smoke from
the firestorm would loved high in the
atmosphere
cooling darkening drying the Earth's
surface for more than a decade it would
obliterate food crops putting billions
at risk of starvation yet we continue to
live in denial of this existential truth
but Faulkner in his Nobel speech also
issued a challenge to those who came
after him only by being the voice of
humanity he said can we defeat fear can
we help humanity and there and I guess
duty is to be that voice the voice of
humanity of humanitarian law to speak up
on behalf of civilians giving voice to
that humanitarian perspective is how we
will create the end of fear the end of
denial and the end of nuclear weapons
and that brings me to my second point
freedom asked international physicians
for the Prevention of nuclear wars the
first-ever anti-nuclear weapons
organization to win this price said on
this stage in 1985 we physicians protest
the outrage of holding entire world
hostage reporters to the moral obscenity
that each of us is being continuously
targeted for extinction and those words
ring true still today we must reclaim
the freedom to not live our lives as
hostages to imminent destruction man not
woman made nuclear weapons to control
others but instead we are controlled by
them
they made us false promises that by
making the consequences of using these
weapons so unthinkable it would make any
conflict impossible that it would keep
us free from war but far from preventing
war these weapons brought us to bring
multiple times during the Cold War and
in this century these weapons continue
to escalate us towards war and conflict
in Iraq in Iran in Kashmir in North
Korea
their existence propels others to join
the race they don't keep us safe they
cause conflicts as fellow Nobel Peace
Laureate Martin Luther King jr. called
them from this very stage in 1964 these
weapons are both genocidal and suicidal
they are mad man's gun held permanently
to a temple these weapons were supposed
to keep us free but they deny us our
freedom it is an affront to democracy to
be ruled by these weapons but they are
just weapons they are just tools and
just as they were created by
geopolitical context they can just as
easily be destroyed by placing them in a
humanitarian context and that is the
task that I can has set itself and my
third point that I want to talk to you
the future I have the honor of sharing
this stage today with Zook with olive
who has made it her life's purpose to
bear witness to the horrors of nuclear
war she and the Hibakusha were at the
beginning of this story and it is our
collective challenge to ensure that they
will also witness the end of it they
relive their painful pasts
over and over again so that we may
create a better future there are
hundreds of organizations in
that are making great strides towards
that future there are thousands of
tireless campaigners who around the
world who work each day to rise to that
challenge and there are millions of
people across the globe who have stood
shoulder-to-shoulder with those
campaigners to show a hundreds of
millions more that a different future
truly is possible and those who say that
that future is not possible
need to get out of the way of those
making it happen
ask the culmination of this grassroots
efforts through ordinary people standing
up to the most powerful this year the
hypothetical marched forwards towards
the actual as 122 nations negotiated and
concluded a UN treaty to outlaw these
weapons of mass destruction the treaty
on the prohibition of nuclear weapons
provides the pathway forward at a moment
of great global crisis it is a light in
a dark time and more than that it
provides a choice a choice between the
two endings the end of nuclear weapons
or the end of us it is not naive to
believe in the first choice
it is not irrational to think the
nuclear States can disarm it is not
idealistic to believe in life over death
it is a necessity all of us face that
choice and I call on every nation to
join the treaty on the prohibition of
nuclear weapons
the United States choose freedom over
fear Russia choose disarmament over
destruction Britain choose rule of rule
of law over oppression and France choose
human rights over terror China
she's Rison over irrationality in India
she sends over senselessness Pakistan
choose logic over Armageddon and Israel
choose common sense of obliteration and
North Korea choose wisdom of Arun to the
nations who believe that they are
sheltered under the umbrella of nuclear
weapons you're enabling of the nuclear
States will not make you any less
complicit in the destruction of others
in your name
and to all nations around the world
choose the end of nuclear weapons over
the end of us this is the choice that
the treaty on the prohibition of nuclear
weapons represents join this treating we
citizens are living under the umbrella
of falsehoods these weapons are not
keeping us safe they are contaminating
our land and water poisoning our bodies
holding hostage our right to life so to
all citizens of the world stand with us
demand your governments side with
humanity and sign this treaty we will
not rest until all states have joined on
the side of reason
no nation today boasts of being a
chemical weapon state no nation argues
that it's acceptable under extreme
circumstances to use sarin nerve agent
no nation to claims the right to unleash
on its enemy playing or polio and that
is because international norms have been
set perceptions have changed and now at
last we have an unequivocal norm against
nuclear weapons monumental strides
forward never beginning with universal
agreement but with every new signatory
and every passing year this new year
reality will take hold this is the way
forward there is only one way to prevent
the use of nuclear weapons prohibit and
eliminate them
[Applause]
nuclear weapons like chemical weapons
biological weapons cluster munitions
landmines before them are now illegal
their existence is immoral their
abolition is in our hands the end is
inevitable but would that be the end of
nuclear weapons or the end of us we must
choose one we are a movement for
rationality for democracy for freedom
from fear
we are campaigners from 468
organizations who are working to
safeguard the future and we are
representatives of the moral majority
the billions of people who choose life
over death and who together will see the
end of nuclear weapons thank you
the speech
the academic to be pleased to
everybody rises for this bitch
no Rachelle visitors that circle
your Majesties distinguished members of
the Norwegian Nobel Committee my fellow
campaigners here and throughout the
world ladies and gentlemen it is a great
privilege to accept this award together
with Beatrice on behalf of all the
remarkable human beings who foam ican
movement you each give me such a
tremendous hope that we can and will
bring the era of nuclear weapon to an
end I speak as a member of the family of
hibachi those of us who survived the
atomic bombing of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
for more than seven decades we have been
working hard for the total abolition of
nuclear weapons we have stood in
solidarity with those harmed by the
production and testing of these horrific
weapons around the world people from
places with long forgotten names
like maroa echo Semipalatinsk morale
andhe became people whose lands and seas
were poisoned with radiation whose
bodies were experimented upon whose
cultures were forever disrupted we are
not content to be victims we refuse to
wait for fiery end or to slow poisoning
of our world we refuse to sit idly in
terror as the so called great powers
took us past nuclear dusk and brought us
recklessly close to nuclear midnight we
rose up we shared our stories of
survival we said nuclear weapons and
humanity's cannot coexist
today I wanted to fill in this hole the
presence of all those who perished in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki I want you to
feel above and around a great cloud of a
quarter million souls each person had a
name each person was loved by someone
let us ensure that their deaths were not
in vain I was just 13 years old girl
when the United States dropped the first
atomic bomb of my city of Hiroshima I
remember that morning vividly at 8:15 I
saw a blinding bluish white flash I
remember having the sensation of
floating in the air when I regained the
consciousness in the total darkness and
silence I found myself pinned under the
collapsed building I knew I was faced
with death I began hearing faint voices
of my classmates around me mother helped
me god help me
then all of a sudden somebody shook my
left shoulder from behind the man saying
don't give up keep pushing keep kicking
you see the Sun way coming through that
opening grow toward it as quickly as
possible as I crawled out the rubble was
on fire most of my classmates in the
same building were burnt to death alive
I saw all around me
utter unrecognizable unimaginable
devastations procession of ghostly
figures shuffled by grotesquely wounded
people they were bleeding burned
blackened and swollen parts of their
bodies were missing flesh and skin from
their bones some with their own eyeballs
hanging in their hands some with their
bellies burst open their intestines
hanging out the foul stench of burnt
human flesh filled air thus with one
bomb my beloved City was obliterated
most of its residents were civilians
who incinerated vaporized carbonized
among them members of my own family and
351 schoolmates of mine in the weeks
months and years that followed many
thousand more more would die often in
random and mysterious ways from the
delayed effects of radiation still to
this day
radiation is killing survivors whenever
I remember Hiroshima the first image
that comes to my mind it's my
four-year-old nephew his little body
transformed into an unrecognizable
melted chunk of flesh he kept begging
for water in a fake voice until his
death released him from agony to me he
came to represent all the innocent
children of the world threatened as they
are at this very moment by nuclear
weapons every second of every day
nuclear weapons and danger everyone will
love and everything we hold dear we must
not
totally this insanity any longer
through our agony and the sheer struggle
to survive and to rebuild our lives from
the ashes we Abacha became convinced
that we must warn the world about these
apocalyptic weapons time and again we
shared our testimonies but still some
refuse to see hiroshima and nagasaki
atrocities as war crimes they accepted
propaganda that these were good bombs
that had ended the war just war it was
this myth that led the disastrous
nuclear arms race a race that continues
to this day nine nations still threaten
to incinerate entire series to destroy
life on earth to make a beautiful world
an inhabitable
for our future generations the
development of nuclear weapon signifies
not a country's elevation to greatness
but to its descent to the darkest depths
of depravity
these weapons are not necessary evil
they are the ultimate evil
on the seventh of July this year I was
overwhelmed with joy when the great
majority of the world's nation voted to
adopt the treaty on the prohibition of
nuclear weapon having witnessed humanity
at its worst I witnessed that day
humanity at its best
we hibachi had been waiting for the band
for 72 years let this be the beginning
of the end of nuclear weapons
all responsible leaders will listen to
this will sign this treaty and history
will judge harshly those who rejected
know long no longer shall they obstruct
theories mask the genocide Oh reality of
their practices no longer shall
deterrence reviewed as anything but a
deterrent to disarmament no longer shall
we live under the mushroom cloud of fear
to the officials of nuclear weapon
nations and to their accomplices under
the so called nuclear umbrella I say
this listen to our testimony heed our
warning and know that your actions are
consequential you are each an integral
part of the system of violence that
threaten human kind
there are all we alert to the banality
of evil to every president and prime
minister of every nation of the world I
beseech you join this treaty forever
eradicate the threat of nuclear
annihilation when I was a 13 year old
girl trapped
in the smoldering rubble I kept pushing
I kept moving toward the light and I
survived our light now is a ban treaty
to all in this hall and all listening
around the world
I repeat those words that I heard in the
ruins of Hiroshima don't give up keep
pushing keep moving see the light crow
told it tonight
we march through the streets of Oslo
with torches a flame let us follow each
other out of that dark night of nuclear
terror
no matter what obstacles we face we will
keep moving and keep pushing and keep
sharing this light for others this is
our passion our commitment for our one
precious world to survive
whole audience gets up again after the
two impressive speeches by the icon
representatives
big Italians Atsuko burner
it's a furlough of course this thing
as we have CID
lived through the nuclear bomb that's a
little irrational
there will be more music at the Moodle
will sing again with our game chatter
piano in Durham a dream panel region
composer erratically lyrics by no
DeRozan
[Music]
we are gonna go
Gibson
another song composer at this year's
Peace Prize ceremony is soon coming to
an end
the time has come for the royal family
to congratulate this year's winners as
they always do the King also greets the
members of the Nobel Committee
so soon the guests will leave the city
boy
first the Royal musician
[Music]
and then the prizewinners precision will
leave the hall
[Music]
this year's ceremony is over but tonight
will be the traditional Nobel dinner
[Applause]
you